ich habe hier einen Salat für euch den
ihr zu Hause vorbereiten könnt perfekt
Schichten könnt ein Dressing was fertig
ist und dann nehmen wir das ganze mit
zur Arbeit oder zum Beispiel mit in die
Schule
für das Dressing verwende ich einfach
etwas Zitronensaft da kommt jetzt noch
ein gutes Olivenöl mit dazu etwas Salz
und wenn ihr gerne möchtet dabei etwas
zu macht dass es Essigbaum gewürzt dann
einfach nur verschließen und schon ist
das Dressing fertig
beim Salat achte ich jetzt drauf dass
alle schweren Zutaten nach unten kommen
[Musik]
und der leichte luftige Salat nach oben
damit er nicht zerdrückt wird
und fertig so nehme ich den Salat jetzt
einfach mit und kann ihn dann eben schön
zusammenschlüpfen